Mà không nhìn nào có sáng xong rồi,
rồi đi làm sẽ em giống người làm vừa trong kai,
kèng về sau khi nền đam mê,
mẹ cảnh nhiều quyết định hiểu việc về tâm xóc vừa.
Từng có nhiều năm làm kế sáng với tuyệt vụ nhập ủng đình,
chỉ hiểu hiện 8 năm tối,
quyết định ý việc để có thời gian chăm sóc khu vụ nhỏ cảnh nhà.
Không dân, cũng phải hai năm em ơi đưa ra được kết quyết định,
tán bỏ rất nhiều thức,
vào nhiều 3 ăn học,
rồi xam rồi, kì vọng của vá mẹ em cũng xin nỉ,
đầu phải là mình về vừa là mình không kým được tình,
đó là mong vệnh mừng yêu thích như mà mình cũng sẽ có vắng kým được thu nhập.
Khu vâng của chỉ hiện ở phường lòng phức thành phố của chỉ mình
rộng năm trăm mít dù được chi thành ba khu,
trong hơn 2 mi lại cho cụ kết nhau.
Phong việc của em,
áo, tài nào từ sáng dưới sáng,
chúng tôi vừa,
trong kai,
khu hạt kiến này đầu tình,
kết khó trang là ký khò lần lắm đó,
khi chỗ này đủ ý là kế,
kế khai nó chết,
chảy hòa,
2 bay dụng rao,
chảy tạo nó cụ phần thứ coa,
nó thúc cơt được.
Tình nghĩ mà rồi mình trong tự cần,
kế chỉ cậm rau của mình,
nó em kìa nghe nghe không?
Hoài ra,
chỉ hình chia sẽ video trên mạnh sả hối,
để ghi lại hành trên,
và bán thêm châu,
tạo thêm một thu nhập.
Con ra mẹ thì cũng hả,
cũng hả,
đặt cơm,
có gì chú,
cho mấy cầm mẹ để cầm tỏ trọng,
thì biết,
thì bán thêm biết,
thì cà bán thêm cà,
cũng có tìm ra tình dâu.
Điều nào,
kính tảy a thì kế ngồn khu nhập,
chú có bàn kế mức lưu,
mà em đi làm,
dành thầm đâu,
thì mà đó với em,
mà như vậy,
đủ rồi,
có nhiều thời gian ca gia đình,
thì mình hế cuộc sống mình nó ý nghĩa,
và em hải lòng,
vôy kế cuộc sống hiện tại của em.